two more leftist Democrat ladies entered
the 2020 presidential contest over the
weekend prompting America to respond we
will analyze the official this war and
kick off as well as Klobuchar snowy
global warming warning then John Kasich
does yoga Virginia politicians do
minstrel shows and the Grammys award
people for neither singing nor dancing
finally the Pope pals around with the
grand Sheikh in Arabia
while democrat congresswoman Ilan Omar
defames the Jews I'm Michael Knowles and
this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
really interesting religious realignment
going on right now in America and
throughout the world this story is
probably the most underreported news
story it happened last week the Pope
visited the Arabian Peninsula for the
first time in two thousand years no Pope
has ever gone down there this is all I
think finally a Western reckoning on
scientific materialism on atheism on the
religion or ear religion that came out
of the Enlightenment this is a huge news
story it really really matters and so of
course the mainstream media are not
reporting on it but we will report on
what looks to be an alliance between the
Muslim world in the religious Western
world against atheism but first we have
got to cover 2020 we have got to cover
Liz Warren's I think 7th campaign
kickoff how many times is she kicked off
this campaign already I don't know we'll
cover that will cover Klobuchar will
cover the Dark Horse Democrat but first
let's make a little money honey with
untuck it untuck it listen here's a tip
no guy looks very good in a long bulky
dress shirt when it is untucked you
might think oh I'm a cool guy yeah I
look casual yeah hey don't worry I don't
even need to tuck in my shirt
usually with most shirts this ends up
looking sloppy that's because those
shirts were not meant to be worn that
way untuck it make sure it's
specifically designed to be worn
untucked did you get it it's in the name
you should get that they're really good
these shirts are cool I noticed because
Jeremy the god-king boring would wear
them constantly and I was like Oh Jeremy
man those shirts look pretty cool and he
was like right that's untuck it I can
afford that because I'm your boss now it
turns out you can get a special offer
from untuck adjust for my listeners go
to untuck it calm or visit one of untuck
it's 50 stores across the u.s. and
Canada I've actually before they were a
sponsor I went into one they fitted me
out for a shirt great customer service
untuck it even offers free shipping and
returns on all orders in the US use
promo code MKS for 20% off your first
purchase don't say I never did nothing
for you if you want the perfect fitting
sure regardless of your shape and size
try the original untucked
shirt remember use promo code MKS for
20% off your first purchase Elizabeth
Warren is officially running for
president again I know it was she
officially was doing it three months ago
and then officially this she has another
campaign kickoff and here she is kicking
off her first day on the trail by trying
to be Donald Trump every day there's a
racist tweet a hateful tweet something
really dark and ugly and what are we as
candidates as activists as the press
gonna do about that we're gonna chase
after those every day every day are we
gonna let him use those to divide us you
know here's what bothers me the time we
get to 2020 Donald Trump may not even be
President
[Applause]
[Music]
in fact he may not even be a free person
oh no she didn't oh wow
here she is coming out swinging feisty
Elizabeth Warren and she's gonna fight
back against Donald Trump by doing a
really lame version of his original joke
that's Wow that's our gal Liz Warren a
woman who'd be I mean she is a lecturer
so the fact that she's lecturing people
is not surprising we should expect that
but it's so tedious it's so grating I
can't imagine anybody really likes the
sound of this she can't pull off doing
Trump she's not Trump she's very much
not Trump for one I don't think Donald
Trump is even one one-thousandth Native
American she is obviously not Trump
she's trying to do that great Trump
moment from the debate with Hillary
Clinton here it is someone with the
temperament of Donald Trump is not in
charge of the law in our country because
you'd be in jail
Secretary Clinton it's not when Liz
Warren does that it's not even close he
doesn't write on the cuff says I don't
want to be in a world where Donald Trump
is president yeah you'd be in jail
that's why boom mic drop whereas she
does it it's obviously planned it's
obviously contrived and it's in this
weird language he might not even be a
free person in 2020 yeah uh-huh
ooh am i right she can't do it she's the
definition of a limousine liberal she's
a racial fraud the race stuff is dogging
her it's gonna keep dogging her MSNBC
joe scarborough seems to think that by
the spring all of that Native American
stuff will be behind her it won't be I'm
telling you will not be behind her why
not because if she could have figured
out a way to put this behind her she
would have done it already she would
have done it
for the two years now that Donald Trump
has been calling her Pocahontas and for
even longer than that that these these
allegations have been around that her
fraud has been exposed if she had an
answer she would have given an answer
but she doesn't have
she doesn't have an answer and so this
is by the way why she keeps doing all of
these campaign kickoffs for okay she
made a whole huge deal about the
exploratory committee
she'd make an old huge deal about the
beer video she's made she's trying to
get a fresh start
she needs a fresh start because she
knows that her racial fraud is gonna
destroy her campaign if it hasn't
already which obviously it has so she
keeps saying okay well if we're gonna do
a clean break we're gonna address the
racial fraud first and then once that's
taken care of then we're gonna start a
new campaign so actually before she even
announced the first announcement she
released that genetic test
she thought okay I'm gonna release this
genetic test it's gonna show that I may
be one 1024 Native American and then
people will say that it's okay that I
called myself Native American and then
we can announce Fresh Start
whoops didn't work and then okay the
beer now I'm getting into a social media
campaign all that official stuff is
beyond now I'm gonna have a fresh start
I like beer I still like beer I'm not a
robot I hug my husband I mmm total flop
people made fun of her for days because
she's not okay Zia Cortez because she
doesn't she's just so stiff and not
credible and okay well that's but now
the official launch of the campaign
there's no fresh start there's no fresh
start for Elizabeth Warren it's not
going to happen she also just doesn't
have the qualities that make for
effective candidates I have seen
candidates otherwise good candidates who
like their face didn't look great there
may be a little bit when they spoke
their nose pinched up too much maybe it
really these things really matter it
seems superficial but look it's
democratic politics this is
superficiality you're talking about a
popularity contest here they're of
course going to accuse Republicans and
conservatives who criticize Liz Warren
of chauvinism or sexism or misogyny or
whatever it it's not misogyny it's
applying the same standard to male and
female candidates you hear how many
times did we hear during the 2016 race
that Ted Cruz was facially challenged I
think it Ted Cruz himself joked about
this is just the sort of scrutiny that
public candidates are up for especially
in a Democratic Republic where people
are voting for you she just doesn't have
it there is a more interesting candidate
who is now also officially running for
president I'm actually I mean I'm
damning with faint praise here because
most candidates are more interesting
than Liz Warren but Amy Klobuchar
senator from Minnesota actually makes a
much stronger case than Liz Warren in
our nation's heartland at a time when we
must heal the heart of our democracy and
renew our commitment to the common good
I stand before you as the granddaughter
of an iron ore miner as the daughter of
a teacher and a newspaper man as the
first woman elected to the United States
Senate from the state of Minnesota to
announce my candidacy for president of
the United States
all right before I make fun of this
announcement there's a lot to make fun
of here I do want to point out the
positives she comes across as a much
stronger candidate just in general she
looks stronger she looks better
she's smiling in a way that liz warren
hillary clinton all the time they would
be scowling the only time they weren't
scowling is when they do that awkward
forced laugh that hillary haha oh well
we're gonna run and i'm gonna hurt haha
you know and there's that just that
brief moment amy klobuchar much more
naturally gets it she gets democrat
politics
she's better on the stump she's better
with voters and she comes across as
stronger Liz Warren comes across as a
frail college lecturer Amy Klobuchar she
is a career politician this lady has
been running for office for a very long
time
she was an exec you know county
executive or something in Minnesota
she's taken the long way up and she's
learned a thing or two on the trail so
that's all good for her
the downside for her is she also doesn't
have a great voice the other downside
for her is that she's from true-blue
Minnesota Minnesota has voted for the
Democrat in every single presidential
election since 1976 even in 1984 when
Ronald Reagan won 49 states he won the
whole country Minnesota still managed to
go blue so she doesn't bring a whole lot
with her and she doesn't have much of a
reason to moderate she doesn't have much
pushing her toward the center which
might help her in a general election
but then she has one really awful thing
going for her she has one really awful
thing going for her that actually every
other Democrat candidate has to deal
with we'll get to that in a second but
first Valentine's Day is coming up there
were only three days left until
Valentine's Day fellas I've been in your
shoes I know I we've all been there I
just made my dinner reservation last
night for Valentine's Day I only by the
grace of God was I able to get a dinner
reservation get your flowers now if you
don't have the perfect surprise already
picked out you're cutting it really
close right now pull over your car go
check out my friends at 1-800 flowers
dot
komm they have amazing deals on vibrant
and romantic Valentine's rose bouquets
arrangements and more starting at just
$29.99 like a teen romantic red roses
for $29.99 they are beautiful I gave
some to sweet little Elise already we
have them sitting on our kitchen table
they're just gorgeous they come in just
a really nice box so that they don't
really get damaged along the way
beautiful flowers you have to hurry them
do it right now
roses from 1-800 flowers are picked at
their peak they are shipped overnight to
ensure freshness and her amazement they
last they're just really nice and $29.99
is an amazing deal for a teen romantic
red roses that won't last very long pick
your delivery date let 1-800 flowers
handle the rest when it comes to
Valentine's Day I don't settle for
anything less than my rose Authority
1-800 flowers calm to order Valentine
bouquets arrangements and more starting
at $29.99 like a teen romantic red roses
for $29.99 and go to 1-800 flowers com
click the radio icon enter promo code
khofifah COV fe fe order today save at
1-800 flowers calm promo code cough fac
OV e f e f e radio code khofifah check
it out okay
the one really bad issue that Amy
Klobuchar has to deal with that all of
them have to deal with is timing that
the timing is the issue because it
broadly things are all breaking in
Donald Trump's direction right now
one after another even right down to
this beautiful moment from the
announcement speech Amy Klobuchar
standing there as snow is pouring down
covering her head and what does she
choose to focus on global warming here's
another one
climate change the people the people are
on our side when it comes to climate
change
why because like you and I they believe
in science that's why in the first 100
days of my administration I will
reinstate the clean power rules and the
gas mileage dead
and put forth sweeping legislation to
invest in green jobs and infrastructure
and on day one we will rejoin the
international climate agreement we will
do all of that on day one just as soon
as I dig myself out of the blizzard that
I am certainly finding mine must be
caused by global warming in the global
warming blizzard that is coating my hair
in snow day one we will do it really bad
timing
in this case really particularly bad
timing because she's giving it a speech
in part on global warming I mean she's
made this a big issue this is the big
left-wing issue we talked about this a
little bit I was in Raleigh North
Carolina yesterday giving a speech at
the young America's Foundation
environmentalism global warming is the
issue for the left I know it just seems
like a pet issue it just seems like okay
environmentalism is one raising taxes is
another or health care now
environmentalism is the whole thing
because it's the religion the religion
is the religion of global warming and
the religion is then totalizing it kind
of takes in part everything so this
green New Deal is the great example of
that the green new deal for some reason
includes a jobs program it mandatory
universal basic income it destroys the
eighty eight percent of the American
energy industry it destroys and then
rebuilds every single residential and
non-residential building in America it
takes over a sixth of the US economy and
forces a socialist health care program
that destroys private insurance and
eliminates patient choice why is all of
that in an environmental bill what does
that have to do with the Delta smelter
the polar bears seemingly nothing unless
you realize that this is not about
protecting the natural environment this
is the totalizing religion of the left
and through this religious bill they'll
get everything they want the green New
Deal sets up a mechanism a select
committee such that they can pass any
law they want the committee
without any accountability to voters
without any campaigning without any
democratic or republican politics just
pure tyranny they get everything through
it's the whole system and so that's why
they all have to focus on global warming
and like every other false religion no
amount of data are going to convince
them to drop it like all other false
religions they can be standing there
waiting for the world to end the world's
gonna end at midnight on Tuesday they're
all out there waiting for the world to
end midnight comes it's 12:02
everybody's still alive what happens to
their faith their faith doesn't go away
they double down on it they say oh it's
gonna be really bad when it happens
tomorrow they're gonna double all down
on this so what you're hearing now this
is the the left-wing response to a
president Trump made this same joke
about Amy Klobuchar I said ah not a
great look and you're covered up in snow
you look like a little snowman talking
about global warming and they say you
idiot weather isn't climate weather
weather is when one discrete weather
event happens and climate is the
totalizing religion that we believe in
that's basically the difference so they
say one single event in the weather
doesn't move the needle on global
warming one way or the other it's the
totality of events except they don't
abide by that rule when the weather
helps their position when there's some
big flood they say its global warming
when there's a heat wave they say its
global warming when one year is hotter
than in the previous year they say that
is global warming when there's a heat
spell in the middle of summer that is
global warming and now because it's a
total izing religious system it's
unfalsifiable so when the weather is too
cold its global warming when the weather
is too hot
its global warming when the weather
doesn't move at all as it didn't for a
very long period of time between the
late 90s and today when it that when
they global mean temperature doesn't
increase they say that's global warming
too extreme weather moderate weather any
kind of weather is global warming so
then they then they lecture us they say
the weather is in climate
give me a but you've got to pick a lane
you can't have it both ways so despite
the fact that global warming predictions
have not come true despite the fact that
New York is not underwater Florida is
not underwater it's like Al Gore
predicted it hasn't been underwater for
ten years no evidence that it's
catastrophic despite all of this they're
gonna stick to it and Amy Klobuchar on
day one is going to rejoin the Paris
climate Accord except what about that
evidence we're not in the Paris climate
Accord a lot of other countries are we
are leading the way on meeting the goals
of the Paris climate Accord we actually
are reducing air pollution and the other
signatory countries to the Paris climate
Accord are not it's just a it's just
words to them it's just joining in on an
ideology and has nothing to do with the
reality even though we are already
exceeding the other nations who actually
join the Paris climate Accord doesn't
matter it's just that sort of radicalism
and they need to be this radical the
left Democrats need to be this radical
this is the part of the campaign where
everybody is really far left-wing to
shore up the Democrat base especially
because there are early primaries in our
California moved up the Democrat primary
so they've got to be really radical now
then they'll try to moderate in the
general election except there's this
awful confluence of now the Democrats
are currently especially radical the
Democrat Party is now today especially
radical you had the green New Deal
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez actually wiped
the green New Deal frequently asked
questions sheet off of her website she
took it off because we all made fun of
it so much she took it off her website
and then her strategists went around and
said that Republicans had made it up the
strategists went around said oh they
were hoaxes from Republicans it was on
your website we have screenshots you
can't get slightest forever and the
Democrats by the way for that matter
can't actually back down from the
policies that were included in the green
New Deal they have to remain this
radical all of this is redounded to
president Trump's benefit it's why
Rasmussen today as president Trump's
approval rating at 52% these are
shocking highs everything is breaking in
Donald Trump's direction
right now this is going to cause a lot
of problems for Democrats and we haven't
even gotten to the best the best
Democrats for president Trump's
re-election yet all of whom are in
Virginia but first let's make just a
little bit more money honey just but you
know just a little tiny touch with
Boleyn branch oh you're gonna love
Boleyn branch you know Valentine's Day
is coming up folks just saying if you
want to you know if you want to get
ready for Valentine's Day the right way
at least what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
make sure my bowl and branch sheets are
on my bed a bowl and branch these are
the greatest sheets I've ever slept on
getting a great night's sleep is easier
and more affordable than you think
you don't need you know sleeping pills
you don't you just need to change your
sheets and that's why you should check
out bowl and branch everything they make
from bedding to blankets is made from
100% organic cotton which means they
start out super soft and they get softer
over time if you buy really expensive
really high-end luxury sheets they can
cost $1,000 or more in the store but
Boleyn branch are only a couple hundred
bucks because they cut out the middleman
and they go directly to you this is why
everyone who tries ball and branch loves
them I love them they have thousands of
five-star reviews
Forbes The Wall Street Journal and Fast
Company are all talking about Boleyn
branch even three u.s. presidents sleep
on bold and branch sheets shipping is
free you can thriving for 30 nights if
you don't love them send it back for a
refund but you will love them you won't
send them back no risk no reason not to
give them a try and just to get started
right now my listeners get ready for
Valentine's Day think of me in the when
you're putting your sheets on your bed
$50 off your first set of sheets at
Boleyn branch calm promo code Michael mi
CH AE L go to Boland branch calm today
for $50 off your first set of sheets Bo
LL and branch calm promo code Michael mi
CH AE L Boland branch calm promo code
Michael check him out think about me on
Valentine's Day everything is breaking
in president Trump's direction here so
now the Democrats have to own post birth
abortion they have to own destroying
American energy 88% of it they have to
own rebuilding every single building in
the entire United States of America they
have to own a 40 trillion dollar program
where the best guests they have on how
they can pay for it is to print money
that was in the green New Deal
quantitative easing we're just going to
print money at the Federal Reserve if to
own radical health care laws which were
so disastrous to the Obama
administration in 2009 this is why all
of these campaigns have come hobbling
out of the gate which Democrat campaign
have we thought wow that's the one
that's the way is it Spartacus no Kamala
Harris uh uh she started with a mood mix
she can't even run on her own record
Liz Warren she started her campaign like
seven times already Amy Klobuchar
Klobuchar I don't think so ultimately
what this is going to be as a referendum
on President Trump but what are they
gonna run on so you say okay here's what
President Trump is doing president Trump
because here what they're going to do is
say President Trump is terrible on race
it's terrible on race issues he's a
racist and then who were the Republicans
going to point to mm-hmm
you remembering that little guy over in
Virginia oh I'm sorry the two guys in
Virginia who wore black face the two the
Attorney General and the governor they
gonna point to him doesn't look great
they're gonna talk about Donald Trump
being a racist Elizabeth Warren her
entire career defrauded the Texas bar
defrauded Harvard University pretended
to be a Native American so that rate
that that issue is out what are they
gonna say they're gonna say that he's
radical on policy radical on policy the
Democrats want to rebuild every building
in the United States
how's that for radical on policy they
can't the economy is still doing very
well people's tax returns are actually
looking pretty good the Democrats are
trying to pretend they're not people are
getting a tax break this is a big win we
will get to how Virginia how Virginia
Democrats could have stopped the
bleeding could have helped them going
into 2020 but they failed will drink up
those leftist tears will also get to the
Grammys with the Grammys say about our
culture hint it's not great John Kasich
does yoga yuck and we will talk about
the papal visit to Abu Dhabi the
Christian Muslim interfaith dialogue
that really does have a chance of
reshaping the way that we talk about
religion all around the world that
really does stand a chance to reshape
certain religious alliances but first
you've got to go to daily wire.com if
you're already there thank you
very much you help keep the lights on
you keep Kofi FA in my cup when I've got
my delicious cough FA cup instead of
here on the road I've got a drink out of
paper coffee cups you get me you get the
end reclaim ensure you get the Ben
Shapiro sure you get the Matt Walsh oh
you had to have questions in the mailbag
that's coming up on Thursday you get to
ask questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you get everything you get the
left is tears tumblr you get if you have
not yet watched governor Northam
interview on CBS where he doubles down
on everything and says that slavery was
just indentured servitude where people
showed up as if voluntarily and our
shores if you do not have your left is
tears tumblr I'm sorry there's I'm sure
you're just floating in your living room
right now but if you do have your left
is tears tumblr I'm sure that you were
able to survive get it it's important
it's the only fda-approved vessel to
contain the salty delicious leftist
tears also if you're in Atlanta tonight
I'm gonna be speaking at Emory
University it's going to be a ton of fun
the tears will flow it will be wonderful
like beautiful ambrosia go to check it
out at Emory I think we're gonna stream
it online if you can't make it out
otherwise stick around we'll be right
back
so obviously the Democrats have this
broad political problem they have the
national political problem which is that
everything is breaking in Trump's
direction they have the discreet
national political problem which is that
all of their candidates are terrible
they don't have any good candidates even
the leaders like bado have kind of blown
themself up with those weird angsty blog
posts he put on medium even Joe Biden
now polling isn't looking great for him
political advisors are saying he'd be
even weaker than Hillary Clinton Cory
Booker senator spartacus not looking
great Kamala Harris maybe the best of
the bunch still not a strong candidate
not necessarily a national candidate she
is a far left California ideologue then
they have this regional problem which is
the entire state of Virginia entirely
run by Democrats or all racial racist
rapists infanticidal clowns really tough
time and Ralph Northam instead of
stepping down as the governor at which I
guess would elevate an accused rapist
and then if he stepped down I guess that
would elevate another guy who wore black
face which is ostensibly the whole
problem in the first place because no
one's talking about the genocide either
guy who won't step down he went on CBS
and he made things worse indentured
servants from Africa laying it on our
shores and Old Point Comfort what we
call now Fort Monroe and wild also known
as slavery yes yes yes what was that
word you said
slavery yes when the Africans
voluntarily came to America in what were
they I think the year was 1927 when
they've no governor Northam avala - hold
on I'm riffing here listen this guy
cannot win for losing what a maniac if
anything come on me go a little in the
other direction go a little you know
really make clear that you do not Harbor
racial resentment or racial animus
you're not denying facts of history
indentured servants from Africa landed
on our Shore oh boy there
ahoy there what is your vessel doing
here in Virginia well how did you all
get here from Africa not not great and
nobody is having it even on the left
some cynical Democratic strategists are
really trying to spin this they're
trying to put it on Trump you remember
CNN tried to call Ralph Northam a
Republican for a while they just said
well if we just call him a Republican
maybe he will be a Republican CNN
analyst though Nina Turner very
left-wing woman she is having none of it
and I think she is expressing a lot of
diverse tration even among the leftist
Democrats in recent time till the
president has really made this race
issue whether it's about
african-americans certainly he's doing
it all over the board with immigrants
but we need to have this conversation I
cannot well I just can't 1984 1984 Gucci
just a few days ago this is not about
President Trump this is about racism in
the United States of America
congresswoman I hear you but on this we
not blaming President Trump let me let
me just say this he is that I am NOT
going to let continue to let politicians
use this man as the excuse to deal with
racism in this country it's been going
on for far too long in the United States
of America
preach I mean she's half right she's
basically in dining America is this
hopelessly awful bigoted place where
black people don't have any opportunity
that part's not true she is correct
however that Democrat politicians are
never held to account for their obvious
bigotry and I love this here she goes oh
please I just can't I can't not
everything as Donald Trump's fault you
can't the man is a Democrat governor a
sitting Democrat governor is sitting
there he wore blackface 35 years ago he
calls African slaves indentured servants
he won't step down
doesn't really apologize just you can't
make that guy Donald Trump he isn't
Donald Trump you can't do it and I think
the I think left-wing identity politics
groups are gonna have a lot of trouble
going along with the Democrat Party this
year when some of their leading
candidates are racial frauds senator
Elizabeth Warren my tazewell be senator
Rachel Dolezal senator black face you've
got senator what would it be red face
senator red face governor black face two
extremely white people pretending to be
a different race not a great look not
going to help you rile up your base so
at the same time that they're trying to
turn out they're very far left-wing
progressive base they are turning them
off with this obvious fraud and and
Northam says he won't step down why
won't he step down because he's just the
man to make his state his Commonwealth
rather he'll you think you still deserve
this job when so many people are calling
for you to step down well again we we
have worked very hard we've had a good
first year and and I'm a leader I've
been in some very difficult situations
life-and-death situations taking care of
sick children and right now a doctor
right now Virginia needs someone that
can heal there's no better person to do
that then a doctor Virginia also needs
someone who is strong who has empathy
who has courage and who has a moral
compass and that's why I'm not going
anywhere I have learned from this I have
a lot more to learn but we're in a
unique opportunity now again the 400
year anniversary of the history whether
it be good or bad in Virginia to really
make some impactful changes and slavery
in this country yes in this state yeah
he took care of sick children oh he took
care of him all right
he took it there just the language what
a maniac to say I'm a healer I'm a
healer and so that's I'm gonna heal our
state your most famous medical opinion
is that we should kill babies lying on
the table crying after the
been born that's your most famous
medical opinion that you're a healer
then to use the phrase I took care of
the sick children I oh I took care of
don't worry I took care of it I took
care of those children you not gonna be
having any problems with those sick
children anymore I took care of them I'm
a leader what a wacko maniac he every
single wrong thing every single wrong
move he could possibly make he's making
he's doubling down on staying in office
he's silent on the abortion question
he's doubling down on the racial issues
a disaster but then the guy after him is
a bigger disaster he now has two claims
of rape against him Justin Fairfax the
lieutenant governor two claims one at
the 2004 Democratic National Convention
the other from the year 2000 from Duke
now again these are just coming out now
they're certainly they hold together
more than the allegations against Brett
Kavanaugh but we are just hearing about
them now so I actually do urge some
caution I don't want to rush to judgment
the guy is entitled to due process he is
entitled to the presumption of innocence
however given the political situation
it's no surprise that Virginia
legislators want to impeach him the
trouble is they just don't have the
political guts to do it right now
so the Virginia legislature pulled a
possible move to impeach just in Fairfax
the issue with Fairfax by the way is not
even these allegations
who knows if these allegations are true
I guess they should be investigated the
issue with Justin Fairfax is he's even
more radically pro-abortion
than Ralph Northam Ralph Northam is an
idiot Ralph Northam is not an
intelligent man he's also a cynical
politician and he spoke the logic of his
position on abortion on radio
accidentally which is killing babies
after they've been born however he's not
like he hasn't made his whole career on
supporting abortion he hasn't made his
whole career as an abortion activist
just in Fairfax the lieutenant governor
of Virginia is a major abortion activist
he was the vice chairman of Planned
Parenthood of the metropolitan DC area
for years Fairfax is a radical
Russian activists so you've got race
issues rape issues and late term
abortion all very unpopular with the
American people this is not a big win so
every attack on Trump that they're gonna
make in 2020 he's a misogynist he's a
racist gone gone that is gone he's a
misogynist well I don't know
is he the lieutenant governor of
Virginia does he have to somewhat
credible rape allegations against him
made within a week of each other how
about a president Trump is extreme on
abortion because he is so pro-life well
I don't know the American public is a
little bit in the middle on abortion
they the vast majority of people don't
believe in outlawing all forms of
abortion immediately from the moment of
conception but the vast vast vast
majority of the American people oppose
late term abortion they think it should
be illegal they're gonna point right to
Virginia right to governor healer
governor black face infanticide will
maniac healer not gonna work and then
you have the dark horse candidate the
dark horse democrat party candidate
where is he the one and only John Kasich
well I took my first yoga class today
right beside my wife you know it's
pretty hard pretty challenging but I
kind of figured out it's not about me
versus the world it's trying to get the
most out of what I've got and that's to
stay patient don't get frustrated and I
got to continue because change is really
good it keeps you young as you're
looking into the future how was this man
ever a Republican governor also is it
possible for him to say more incorrect
things in that short period of time is
it actually possible to disagree with
every single syllable a man others as
one disagrees with that stupid oh my
gosh he's there like a little child he's
wearing you know these this clothing in
public this yoga clothing so I just came
from yoga and you know I don't want to
compete against anybody it's just I'm
just competing against myself and I
really like yoga and you know what I
love you know what concern
Vuitton's love you know what is is
really this is gonna help him in the
primary campaign I think you know what
conservatives love change
I think that's conservatives favorite
thing change you dummy what are you
thinking so oh my god we the only thing
that I can think the first thing I
thought when I saw this actually is it
validates Matt Walsh entirely that Walsh
is just completely correct he is a
prophet he said Yoga is satanic it's
always wrong it's always terrible yeah
he's right John Kasich proved that also
the only thing I could think when I
thought of the implications of this
video are is John Kasich gonna run in
the Democrat Reimer I'm serious I'm not
actually making a yoga joke here other
than to say he is exclusively saying
things that Democrats like he is saying
that change is really really good and we
need to change like maybe our political
parties I would not be surprised if this
man jumps into the Democrat primary for
president he obviously won't last very
long but I would not be surprised
talk about rudderless talk about
opportunistic talk about a cautionary
tale
does anybody whenever anyone from
wide-eyed optimists to people who had
genuinely want to serve their country to
those weird sociopaths who are you know
start running for Congress at the age of
24 and a half and immediately insist on
being in Congress the earliest they
possibly can all of those people does
anybody say I want to be John Kasich
when I grow up
talk about a cautionary tale if you
marry yourself to the spirit of the age
you will find yourself a widower in the
next we've got to get to the Grammys the
Grammys rap we always talk about
politics culture and religion we're
actually gonna follow that exact path
today because there's a lot of
interesting movement on all of them and
I'm not talking about John Kasich
movement into the Democrat Party I'm not
talking about Amy Klobuchar --zz
movement into the 2020 race I'm talking
about this movement this reaction
against the Democrat Party with some
weird politics going on with some weird
you don't
you've got identity politics people on
the left criticizing the Democrats you
obviously have the Republicans and in
the Grammys this confusion comes out
clearly because our culture is very
confused Michelle Obama opened up
tonight and she opened up with comments
that are exactly correct
from the Motown Records I wore out on
the Southside to the who run the world
songs that fueled me through this last
decade music has always helped me tell
my story and I know that's true for
everybody here whether we like country
or rap or rock music helps us share
ourselves she's absolutely right
I am not the biggest fan of Michelle
Obama as we all know she got that
exactly right first of all they love her
there she is hollywood's darling she
could become the next media mogul she
could probably run for president and
raise a lot of money at George Clooney's
house they love her and what she said is
right music does tell our story it's the
most important art form we have known
this since the ancient Greeks music
stirs our soul hearing is the most
important sense that's why we always
hear the word of the Lord that's why we
have to have perfect pitch that's why
there's always you hear the voice of God
the breath the music tells our story it
shares ourselves and shares who we are
what story are we telling if this is our
Grammys if this is our Music Award what
story are we telling music really does
matter music really can define a people
culture defines our politics and music
is the most important cultural form just
to give you a glimpse of what our story
is of what our culture is the breakout
performance of the night trending all
over Twitter considered the most
magnificent thing all night at the
Grammys it involved neither singing nor
dancing ladies and gentlemen cardi B
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what on earth is that I know I sound
like a fuddy-duddy but I'm right so I
don't really care what there's no
singing that occurred there's very
little music at all
there's percussion which arouses the
bass passions but there's very little
music we're a little melody very little
harmony if any and there wasn't even
dancing at least if it's just percussion
but there's dancing at least there's
something artistic about that who's not
even dancing it was just her sitting
around lying around humping the floor
briefly I heard her yell something about
money there was no music in the music it
was the breakout performance of the
night what story does that tell what
culture is that and if politics is
downstream of culture as we always
talked about what sort of politics comes
out of that culture what sort of
government is a people who define
themselves by that culture what sort of
government are they capable of or is
anyone capable of self-government if
that's your culture how I mean this is
where DB is our defining pop culture
we're in it she's there this is and this
is obviously our culture has been
declining for a very long time now what
story is that
what art form what veneration what
tradition are we really talking about
here it's just tripe now there was one
upside to the Grammys I have to say my
friend joy villa she came out she always
does this she comes out in a crazy dress
that's right-wing she's done this for
the past few years so one year she wore
a Magga dress then the next year she
wore a pro-life dress which was like a
picture of a little baby in the womb and
said choose life great dress this year
she outdid herself it was her best one
yet she wore the wall it was the wall
she had she had barbed wire going around
her neck and then on the back it said
build the wall but it was written like
Pink Floyd's the wall you know another
brick and
wall it was all done in the spirit of
that album really funny and now some
conservatives won't talk about this some
conservatives have written joy villa off
because they think that she's a fraud
they says and I've seen I've read all of
the pieces about this they say well
she's a Scientologist well she used to
be a Bernie bro well I think she's being
disingenuous well god
my thought is who cares who cares that
what we're talking about here is you've
got this woman joy Villa wore a right
wing dress to the Grammys got a ton of
attention for it if that helps her out
great if it helps out the cause great I
really get a huge kick out of that I
really like the dress I think it was
clever it was smart it was very funny it
was cheeky at a wild cultural event
great I love it
wonderful give me more of that give me
more of that dress well done to joy
before we go we have to talk about the
papal visit to Abu Dhabi this I was
actually supposed to go to this last
week but I had pre-scheduled speaking
engagements I wasn't able to go to it
was the first-ever visit by a pope to
the Arabian Peninsula for so long there
has been a movement to expel Jews and
Christians from Arabia the birthplace of
Islam but the United Arab Emirates Abu
Dhabi invited Pope Francis to come to
meet with Sheikh Ahmed el-tayeb the
grand Imam of al-azhar and kaya Cairo
and to have there was an open-air papal
mass for 120,000 people this was a huge
moment
nobody really reported on it and what
Pope Francis railed against here was it
wasn't against the global warming or
wasn't against capitalism per se what it
was against was faithless modernity and
the Imam talked about this - they were
railing against hyper individualism they
were railing against utilitarianism
they were both railing against the
radicalism that led to the atheism that
we've been dealing with for the last 300
years or so this is really cool
it was predicted the Catholic Herald
pointed this out this was predicted in
Pope Benedict's a 2006 Regensburg
lecture the most important duration of
the 21st century Pope Benedict
obviously considered wide laver a
conservative figure he predicted this
that the real threat to our civilization
is faithless modernity ate this narrow
scientism that ignores all of the grand
questions the idea that man's origin and
destiny the questions raised by religion
and ethics have no place within the
purview of collective reason end quote
that's what they were railing against
and so what you're seeing here is one
after so much Christian persecution in
the Middle East you have an arab
government inviting the pope in this is
historic the UAE should be commended for
this this is a big deal this is really
good but what you also have is an
interesting discourse going on between
Christians and Muslims against
faithlessness against modernity I think
this is exactly right I think they've
got this right I think the great threat
to the West that will corrode us and eat
us out from within is atheism is this
shallow rationalism is this pathetic
culture of nihilism that has created
anxiety depression over prescriptions
suicide epidemics all over the West
there are some people who fear invading
Muslim migrants or something in Europe
sure that's a that is an issue you have
an issue when you have huge populations
invading countries but what allowed the
countries to be eaten out from within it
is that faithless modernity it is
cutting away the tradition on which you
have built your civilization the the
very ideas that allow you to have
Western science Western philosophy
Western thought by cutting those off at
the root that is the great threat to our
civilization I think it's the why the
mainstream media won't cover this event
there's a very good event and you know
I've been very harsh on the Francis
pontificate when I've thought it's
necessary to criticize it I thought this
was a very good move so I'll end on a
happy note happy note for the West happy
note for the church happy note for
conservatives said no for Democrats
tough tough beginning to the week tough
beginning to 2020 all right that's our
show I will be at Emory to
I hope to see you there if I don't see
you there I will be back in the studio
coming up soon no show tomorrow we'll
have a show on Friday in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show see you soon
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa
of era production assistant Nick Sheehan
the Michael Noel's show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19